[Music]
are you okay
she said she was feeling better we see
that regularly with schizophrenia
but it can't be cured
[Music]
okay hanging in there
honey your father's gonna take the door
off the hinges if you keep blocking it
did you hear that there was a girl next
door screaming for help
ryan there's nobody out here there's a
little girl in your attic i saw her
there's no one up there she's lying
you're telling me that your neighbor
kidnapped a little girl and has her
chained in her attic right
i just need you to trust me i do all
right
there's no one up there your mind is
just playing tricks on you
please stay away from that house this is
a serious accusation one that'll likely
have equally serious consequences
what the hell right he said she works
monday through friday we've been helpful
to mention it was at our school
[Music]
[Music]
i don't care what if it was me i'm not
just gonna sit here
your mind is just playing tricks on you
[Music]
[Music]
you